i know you'll want to hear this we now
have the official confirmation uh that
uh michael gove uh previously cabinet
office minister and chancellor the duchy
of lancaster
is the new
uh communities and housing secretary so
michael gove uh takes on that role which
is technically a mid-cabinet uh level
job but obviously very important
given the pledges the government's made
about sorting out the housing crisis you
surprised by that move john
well it had been tipped uh there was
there was speculation he might go to the
foreign office that's gone to liz trust
mr gove has a record in white's hall as
a problem solver and a doer and somebody
who gets things done sometimes of course
he upsets the establishment you remember
back when he was education secretary and
of course at that time dominic cummings
was working for him uh he very much
upset the
education establishment so much that
david cameron moved him but then he had
a good record as environment secretary
and he is a minister who gets things
done and there is a big entry for mr
gove because of course he has to sort
out the
mess some mps would call it a fiasco of
the government's planning reforms which
are blamed for the loss of uh the
cheshire mission by-election to the
liberal democrats
robert generic clearly has paid the
price for a number of uh gaffes if you
like the uh the row involving a
a tax deal for richard desmond um after
he was uh sitting next to him at a tory
donor's dinner uh the planning reforms
clearly have been blamed by uh
many conservative mps on mr generic so
michael gove is somebody who will sort
that out and he does have a good track
record on environmental issues as well